so does that mean would you would you uh
have a relationship with someone that
was in porn
um a serious loving relationship and
knowing that they had sex with 2 345
people no no see see that number's a
little skewed I don't think it's that
many oh it's more like five thousand
three hundred
[Music]
welcome back everybody to another
special episode of the careful boys
where we today have Mr Jimmy Zhang in
the hot seat y'all hello
dang good so uh welcome to the hottest
seat on the interwebs where we ask the
hottest questions okay we're gonna watch
out it gets really hot in that chair bro
your ass is gonna burn almost hot though
sometimes we don't get hot at all but we
always definitely start very cold and
dry is also a good word to use and we
start with Bart we're gonna warm up
slowly but I think we start really
[__] cold bar head on with a cold man
okay
can you repeat after me
let's do it
that's not even a cool question that is
a whole question
he asked him if he could repeat after
him that's part of the question can we
even put that on probably not we're not
trying to say any words that's gonna
[__] get us demonetized
we'll keep that because it's funny
it's even funnier if it's if it's
silencer and they don't know what he
said hey you didn't take the bait that's
good bro you got to make that a real
just decide it's embarcos
clip
so uh for the safety of the channel
let's start over uh we're gonna take
that we're gonna take that bit back to
Bart's going to start with a really cool
question right let's let's
no
of another cold question okay here
let's say you're swimming
okay
starfish comes out of nowhere
I love it
and grabs you on your dick what sound do
you make oh
[Applause]
so you said you grew up in a New York
yeah why did you decide to come to L.A
that's an LA accent by the way what is
that one it's a New Yorker saying la oh
both with New York no no is that
supposed to a New York accent
this is going well to Ming Dynasty
accent I don't like there was a there
was a a YouTuber uh by the name I don't
know if you know Elliot Troy but another
YouTuber he uh this is during coven he
he said like what are you doing during
covet I'm like nothing do you want to
come to LA live in this house this big
giant Creator house with me and like a
couple other like YouTubers and I was
like [__] yeah I'm not doing anything
Elliott Choice sounds dope yeah is he a
comedian no no no no no no no uh he's uh
he's like a college lifestyle YouTuber
oh lifestyle YouTuber and then so you
guys were making like um like a
YouTuber's house and then you guys got
together and was it like let's all make
videos together yeah yeah yeah it was
kind of like that and then everybody in
the house uh yeah just made videos
together how many people are in the
house uh I think six whoa was there any
sex scene amongst you guys like mixing
nah
nah that's what people like to think
right right right right that's that no
there was like some ships you know
people definitely got shipped
um what does that mean relationship yeah
yeah my [__] boom I'm so sorry man
like where people want you today yeah
whether you get in a relationship or not
people might ship you you know right
right people people see you and a girl
like together with chemistry they're
like oh Jimmy that's what they did every
single time a female sat next to one of
us oh yeah yeah that's true but now they
just ship
I feel like I feel I feel like JK fans
were shipping me and Julia hard for a
while dude really ciao yeah no way
anyways this is his hot seat did you
have sex with a porn star recently yeah
that was a year ago it's a good answer
that was a year ago well done okay so
then you liked LA and you decided to
stay in LA and create content in LA and
then just like live your life in L.A
any other ways you can say I like can
you work it in more I think uh around
you know the uh after the the house
ended I'm just I'm like everything's
closed in New York right and it's
housing is cheaper here so why don't you
stay here for a little bit that is a
crazy thing to say
it's just cheaper in L.A what's the
average like like one bat one bed one
bath here we go back to Vegas somehow
what he's gonna bro he's gonna sell you
on Vegas right now
look you York you get this this space
this space you could probably cost
five thousand dollars wow
wow but I mean this space is almost it's
a little bit of like a thousand square
feet yeah it's kind of fancy yeah maybe
five thousand pushing six six six seven
six seven thousand and then in La what
is this space
he's asking you
the question is a bit guys versus real
estate prices okay I'm gonna warm up the
question so you did uh uh have sex with
the porn star what's the the difference
between that and a regular non-porn star
yeah that you were like oh wow this is
different does it really feel like a
flashlight that that dances
I would I would say I would say certain
techniques certain techniques I'm just
like whoa this is I've never seen this
what were some of your favorites just
just like a combination of hand to mouth
yeah
sex I I like to be in control right I
like to I like to do all the work but
then when it comes to like the
extracurriculars right it was it was a
little did you feel it did you want to
come faster yeah was it so good did you
come too fast and you're like ah I might
usually like this but the kind of
kind of graphessional and oh I came too
fast I go fast regardless
[Laughter]
you are the same team yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah so this was even faster well I
think I come really fast just when I'm
uh when I have feelings for someone yeah
yeah so feelings yeah so it wasn't just
a hookup you were you were you were
interested you like them I would say so
wow so does that mean would you would
you uh have a relationship with someone
that was in porn
um a serious loving relationship and
knowing that they had sex with 2 345
people see see that number is a little
skew dude I don't think it's that many
oh it's more like five thousand three
hundred
more numbers
cores of like uh and they have like
similar part but regardless
be curious but I don't I don't know if
it's something I like long term like I
could see myself doing I think uh yeah
part of me is still like traditional in
a sense what is your last relationship
oof uh a year ago why'd you guys break
up see I tell you he was about to marry
a porn star I told you Bart uh
just I different life stages I guess
uh at the time I also wanted to move
back to New York and then she she just
felt like I wasn't prioritizing her so
what where is she from La she's from L.A
oh but you ended jokes on her you didn't
even move back
jokes on her
oh if if there's anything you can say to
her right now because she's subscribed
probably what would you want to say oh
no jokes are hard
jokes jokes oh man jokes on me actually
because I started talking to her uh
recently oh really
oh because you didn't go to leave L.A
but but but then but then but now she's
seeing you on YouTube videos with a porn
star now yeah I'm traveling I'm I'm yeah
I I can't be locked down anymore
oh not currently also just like for my
like life stage I I don't see myself
being in another relationship until like
I'm really ready for it so he you you
wanna you're in the [__] man stage I'm
I'm gonna be a [__] man not a [__] boy
because [__] boy is like 19 all right so
now you're late 20s I'm [__] man I don't
even want to [__] everything I just like
the freedom of of being single to [__]
or not [__] yeah to have the choice
right right right to travel to to to not
have to worry about somebody else
there's couples that still travel and
not worry about each other
you don't have to be in a relationship
jokes on you
what's what's uh like a dark fear you
have dark fear yeah tell us your
scariness stuff oh
fog like sharks or something
that's a suggestion you have no like
fear of failure of any type or like
nurse sharks or sharks that too yeah
like a snapping turtle
I don't even I don't even know are you
scared of heights
you got random phobias
snakes snakes snakes snakes sounds like
a cop-out answer how's your relationship
with their parents death death I'm
really scared of dying oh yeah yeah I
mean when it's over it's done I know
what kind of dying like a sudden death
or just all death
or the idea of when you're dead
emptiness afterwards so like let's say
you see a doctor and a doctor's like hey
you only have six months but that'd be
like oh [__] oh I don't want to know
wouldn't that be all [__] to everybody
no if you're not scared of death they're
like some people are like okay cool I
get it thank you
I don't want to know but if you're if
you're dope like death you don't want to
hear that yeah but yeah but if you're a
psychopath like me I'm like everyone's
gonna die at one point so if you oh mine
says earlier okay fine whatever
I don't want to know
well I I don't know but it's not about
me what about you you want to die no
okay
how's your relationship with your
parents uh now that now I I'm cool with
my mom I could call it my dad's I don't
really talk to him I bet you no I can I
can help you from a guy that has a
turbulent relationship with his father I
can help you out just call him up and be
like yo dad you know I [__] a porn
star and he'll be like you my son again
I don't even think he guessed that world
he
understands he doesn't go
he just he just goes to work goes back
home it's just like a routine what do
you think would have to happen for you
to ask go back and ask your dad for help
I I wouldn't need his help for anything
but like let's say like what do you
think yeah what would have to happen
like let's say YouTube doesn't work
anymore you're bankrupt or would you
move like when would you or would you or
is he like an option that is ruled out
if you hit rock bottom like you'd rather
rather die than yeah ask him for help
uh no I don't know about that like but
he's afraid of death
but if I was on my last
Resort I don't think I would go to I
might go to my mom yeah but my dad it's
hard to like kind of talk to him and get
through too oh like that you have a real
Asian Dad I have a real age yeah the
ones that don't know how to talk to
anybody and they just yell at you has he
ever said I love you to you ah
think so real Asian Dad right Asian Dad
dude yeah
do you have any brothers and sisters I
have a younger brother does he get the
same does he have the same treatment as
you have the same relationship with his
dad uh yes but he had a different
childhood than me like he grew up just
very with a lot more freedom like my
parents are a lot more uh a chill he
also just like grew up just the the cool
kid right he was varsity basketball team
he was very outgoing
um but he didn't have sex with a porn
star am I right
yeah he's on the course maybe if he's a
if he's a football player he [__]
through future porn stars
Joe's usually right when he's not though
he's not but he's usually right yeah no
yeah yeah he has a loving loving
girlfriend yeah yeah oh yeah Joe's wrong
on that one yeah or he's right he did it
when he was in high school there it is
he did it when he was in high school and
then those girls grew up to become only
fans models so what are some of his pet
peeves
serious question
oh man what are your pet peeve
it's like you're dating him dude he's
just trying to save it what's your
favorite color you're talking about his
[__] Varsity brother having sex with
future only fan Stars when he's got a
loving girlfriend like what do we do
here what's the next jump off point
oh [__] well this is the 14 minute Mark
where we definitely turn up the heat or
at least turn it back on to the guest um
Nick go ahead ask him a question
dude that's that's a tough spot right
I'll have one for you what do you think
drives you the most like what's your
the thing that makes you want to keep
pushing forward because that you know
YouTube social media all that stuff it's
like when you don't have your own boss I
mean when when you are your own boss you
don't have to answer to anybody yeah and
that for most people is the hardest part
because most people aren't
self-motivated so the YouTube in a sense
is actually very very difficult because
you have to keep setting your own goals
and push yourself right like what drives
you forward right I think it's just as
seeing the freedom it has allowed
allowed me to to have just the money
that has come in the
yeah I don't even know this internal I I
guess just oh I know what I'm scared of
of working a nine-to-five job really wow
yeah yeah of of being just like a
corporate slave have you worked nine to
five though I I haven't okay it's not
that bad oh it's not yeah security is
kind of nice generalizing old jobs
bro it ain't that bad man this is easy
you should try it but is it because it
brings you back to that place of like
architect major and I I think I think
it's just
College of doing the same thing over and
over with no purpose or like I'm not
really seeing the impact I have on
people like if I'm working for this big
corporate company I I can't see the
emotion that I'm I'm like impacting
another person maybe it may be my boss
I'm just working for a paycheck if I'm
working just for a paycheck like what's
what's my
like what am I doing no fulfillment so
you like you like attaching kind of like
meaning to what you do and then so it's
difficult to do that in a big system
right I see so you're you're like more
like
what do you call like small business
mind like if you were even to do
business that wasn't YouTube it would
always be small business because you
like to be like
like try to hit for a 100 Mil or or plus
just because I feel like just the amount
of pressure that takes to to to to
manage that many people is it's I don't
even know if I'm built for it
um but like a couple mil maybe like with
doing things with my close friends and
just optimizing my life around enjoyment
I think that's something that I want to
do for like the rest of my life yeah
that's not a bad way to live at all
as part like you mentioned fulfillment
right what's probably the most
fulfilling part of your job and the
things that you do right now
um I think just just being able to
impact a lot of a lot of people uh just
from all around the world you know when
people hit me up like yo Jim you you
helped me change my life like I used to
be a shy little version too and now you
know
I have a girlfriend all thanks to you
right oh you know he he got one of his
porn star friends to help a blind kid
lose his virginity okay hold on
it was uh it was two separate videos
actually oh one
uh yeah he was a the blind guy wasn't a
virgin
like I said when Joe's right he's right
when he's running
hey but I thought that was very it was
like philanthropic but like cool but the
blind guy wasn't a virgin yeah he's
saying you're what you're saying is
incorrect
did you get a virgin guy laid I did see
but that one wasn't the blind one all
right but you look so much better if the
blind guy was a virgin because I had
dude I didn't gotta find a blind virgin
dude that's what surprises me it was to
look better than the blind guy who can't
look at things as much I was surprised
that the Blanca wasn't a virgin that's
what I'm he used to
you still came blonde
he had a game before before yeah okay so
well that's that doesn't count
I bet if there was a blind committee
there's like the hardcore ones right
they were like we've been blind since
birth for we don't even know what the
world looks like and then the got blind
committee is like I'm blind and it's
like yeah but you [__] know what the
world looks like you just can't see it
no more yeah and then there's the
god-blind version committee what are
they saying
Jimmy give us a [__]
oh wait can you clarify it though I
[__] it up for you though but he did
the he sorry so he's the Virgin one the
Virgin one talk about the Virgin one
version one was the first series of
videos I did I did with my porn star
friends and basically I just set up a a
flew the guy out got a little Airbnb
gave him makeover gave him some pep talk
and uh yo just just go in there and and
and just you know whatever happens
happens right and then uh well actually
no that's not how it went I I first
spoke to my my porn star friend Violet I
was like hey you know would you be open
to doing like uh like a [__] a fan all
right is that something you want under
your belt and then I'm gonna turn this
into like a wholesome YouTube video
right and she was down so I I uh I just
posted to my fan base I was like yo if
there's any versions out there
send in
you know like fill out this uh
application right and to see how virgin
you are but how did you know
how did you know if they were actually a
virgin or they [__] so they can get
[__] right well you could you could
tell if if they you know I see a picture
of which one's your favorite Yu-Gi-Oh
cards like that
right second of all what uh what's the
closest you got into to lose your
virginity right and and some guys were
getting [__] I'm like nah you guys
you guys aren't that version yeah right
I need guys who can't even speak who
can't even look at a girl all right but
then after we we picked a couple of guys
out we had Violet uh me and violet just
interview them right to see who was a
real version who was who gave off like a
good wholesome Vibe who deserves it yeah
yeah like who's trying too hard [__]
those guys yeah give me a guy that's
honest I need [__] please he's begging
for it yeah
and then and then we flew we we picked
Kevin and then flew him out and uh yeah
just all that that's nice so did he so
did she like shake his hand and he come
and he's like sorry can I come back
tomorrow can we retract I don't know
what happened to them I just left them
in a room together that's sweet what age
were you when you lost to Virginia I was
21. 21 yeah and after that you were just
like I'm gonna [__] share this path
for other people
that's that's the only video I did
actually no I did I did two of them but
I felt like it was yeah there's a lot of
guys out there who uh Buy
you know just by life experience they
don't uh I guess they're not hanging
around with like folks that are are
getting [__] right so like you know
just there's some guys that needs a
little bit of like guidance right like a
plane ticket and a porn star
that's what it takes you know but
um yeah I think back then I I just felt
like you know I went through like years
of like wanting it but like I I didn't
have friends or I I just I was scared I
was you know so I was the video I try to
push this idea of like just trying to
get out of your comfort zone yeah what
that's what I like about their videos is
that like it is fun and entertaining and
it's like whoa I can't believe that's
like a dream come true like you're
you're able to [__] your uh when you're
a fan of a porn star right but then at
the end you're like oh wait like
you know maybe you just got to learn how
to be a social human being and you can
have an authentic relationship
just go out there and start talking to
people yeah and just try just just just
try it as as scary as things are just
just try I think when I first started
just like YouTube and and just uh put
putting myself out there I think I had
like a lot of cripply fear of just doing
[__] just talking to the hot girl
talking to like the growing class you
know even asking for their phone number
like there was a lot of fear right but I
think uh that's why I like I like the
the videos that I do now and and uh it's
a fact it has in other people to like
kind of overcome that so if you saw like
your 15 year old self right now what
would you say to your 15 year old self
uh yeah I'm not like just keep doing you
just just keep being a virgin because
that is ultimately the the reason that I
got to where I am today so I don't even
think I would really change anything
yeah this is part of the evolution I
think so yeah if I was 50 I'd be like
stop doing drugs dude start studying
more
yeah right
[Laughter]
okay